good morning good afternoon good evening
depending on where you're joining us
from welcome to simply learned we are
honored to have you join us today for
creating a killer marketing plan for
your app with your host Nick battle-ax
my name is Richard and after the 2
minute reduction I'll be mostly in the
back helping Nick so that everything
goes smooth until the
question-and-answer time at the end
creating a killer marketing plan for
your app there are so many tools and
abundance of knowledge out there these
days it's hard to know where to start
with your marketing if you have a team
working with you hiring people or
getting started yourself what kind of
training is available for you to succeed
in your own personal career path as a
company as a marketing team hopefully
we'll be able to answer some of that or
get you in the right direction
we will we welcome excuse me welcome
Nick Nick is a digital marketing all
things online marketing expert with over
18 years experience recent regional
trainer at Google lead trainer has
simply learned along with many other
venues as an entrepreneur himself Nick
helps businesses of all sizes to grow
and reach their targeted clients
University of Toronto Rotman School of
Management digital marketing Humber
business gold masters in business
administrative MBA and he has
certificates in business analysis
certified all marketing things google
adwords digital analysis fundamentals
advanced display advanced search double
click wildfire apps and mobile apps
analytics also certified hewlett-packard
social media being ads microsoft social
media consultant just across the board
everything dealing with marketing and
digital marketing we welcome Nick today
with Nick's experience expertise this is
a great place to ask your questions for
your personal path creating a killer
marketing plan for your app as we go
through the webinar let us know what
you're looking for whether it is more
info on a specific topic what path your
career can go in maybe you're a head of
a team and you'd like to know what can
get that team to excel whatever those
questions are we are honored to have
Nick here today with us to address some
of those for those who aren't familiar
with this former webinar
I want to introduce you to your
dashboard if everyone could locate your
dashboard and then locate the question
module you might have to click on the
red arrow to re-expand it in the
question module if you can go ahead and
just say hello
that way we can let Nick know you're
excited to be here this also helps us
check the sound system make sure that
our speakers are working and everybody
can hear us so if you just go ahead and
click on there and say hello to us great
Kunal great to have you here excited to
have you
snow huh I hope I said that right Matt
excellent we're excited to have
everybody here go ahead make this your
best friend while we're on the session
and put your question and questions in
here at the end we'll have a 15-minute
question and answer time and we'll try
to get to as many questions as we can
you didn't come here to listen to me so
we'll go ahead and introduce scuse me I
almost forgot a whole section here feel
free to share with us on your favorite
social channels whether it's Facebook
Linkedin or tweet at Twitter you can use
hashtag SL webinars that way people can
find it and you'll make them wish they
were here you didn't come here to listen
to me came here to listen to Nick so let
me go ahead and bring Nick on here hello
Nick welcome to simply learn today hey
Richard thank you so much for the lovely
its watching it's great to have you all
right go ahead and turn this over to you
and meet myself all right so I believe
everybody is able to hear me loud and
clear and can also see my screen I'm not
just going to go ahead and ask everybody
I'm just assuming everybody can my name
is Nick Richard has given a great amount
of information about me thank you so
much Richard but still the rule says I
have to go ahead and introduce my from
my side too and then we will get started
with today's topic today's webinar topic
which is creating a killer marketing
plan for for your app all right so
that's me
Nick I'm a digital marketing
professional guys I'm just introducing
myself I've been into this profession
for the past 18 years
I've been into the both side of the
industry whether it's to do with the
servicing side and also with their
training
sites I've trained quite a many
professionals and have helped have
various small and medium enterprises
with their meeting their internet
marketing needs with regards to the
certification so I agree to accept quite
a lot of certifications in the digital
marketing industry have made myself
eligible for that whether it's through
Google Bing
Oxford YouTube and so forth and in terms
of my education of Masters in Business
and administration from University of
Toronto yes I do have a full-time role
to take care of guys and my servicing
end which is I have a small Canadian
based internet marketing agency that's
based out of Toronto Canada it's by the
name of your creations Anthony in case
you want to know more about my agency
you can anytime go to your creation
starts here we do provide across all the
internet marketing services for ranging
from social media mobile marketing email
marketing pay-per-click ads and search
engine optimization in quite a lot
excuse me
also I'm a speaker at various schools
colleges and universities some of those
being University of Toronto where I
passed out from Humber College I am and
about I am Bangu and so and some more in
case you want to know more about me you
can anytime go to linkedin.com and just
type in my name Nick Macklin you'll get
to see my entire detail profile you can
read what my clients have to say about
me what how was their experiences in
terms of the projects I have delivered I
have done for them and so forth all
right
and also Richard they mentioned I'm a
trainer with several other organizations
some of those being Google GoDaddy
Microsoft and some others all right so
now today's topic is creating a killer
marketing plan I'm gonna do it go ahead
and get just started with the topic
without wasting any further time so the
very first slide I have got over here
which talks about the objectives which a
mobile app you know is supposed to be
achieving so in I'm assuming most of you
are marketers you have been studying
digital marketing or you are studying
and it's an ongoing process so talking
about mobile app we all know that the
user
my lab is on a peak it's it's increasing
massively there's no there no doubts
about that in terms of understanding how
do we really go ahead and mock it across
an app I'm starting with understanding
what a mobile app is really supposed to
be doing for a marketer an AK is there
for enhancing that the product for value
adding more value to the business or it
is used for several other functions in
an organization like providing customer
support for showcasing the production
offering to the end customer for an
engagement for entertainment purpose for
acquiring new customers whether that
acquisition can be defined as maybe a
sign up of newsletter it can be defined
as a sale on to the website or differs
from situation to situation also the
other objective which a mobile app
really needs across its just brand
awareness also when you have launched
across something in your business or in
an organization may be the immediate
objective is to go ahead and make people
aware make your potential audience aware
about your brand about the new product
which is being glanced across so even
that can be an objective but could be
extending the brand further with
whatever you have at the current point
time or in-app purchases which is
primarily for the e-commerce website so
you you have the products with a price
tag attached to it and you're looking
for people to come onto your app and do
the purchasing when that helps in
building in more revenue for the
organization and not just where revenue
generation is done with the help of
products being sold within the app it
can also serve as a publishing platform
where you can generate revenue through
the advertisement space which you offer
so as an advertiser or
as a publisher from both the end apps
really works in terms of generating
revenue but we're going to focus more in
terms of an advertiser
as a as a organization how a mobile app
which is being created a cards should be
marked with a cross
before the launch of the app guys and
after the launch so that's pretty
interesting you'll the marketing as we
all know it doesn't really start when
the product is being done even at the
initial stage when you're thinking about
launching an app it should start with
how you're going to market it across
because creating an app in today's what
I hope you all of you would agree to me
it's not a difficult job with the with
the availability of so many platforms
which gives you the option to create an
app with the help of templates without
paying in anything of the or by just
paying a very substantial amount it is
not a not a rocket science right the
overall science which goes behind making
an app successful is the way you're
gonna market it across and that's what
we're gonna focus furthermore after
understanding the objectives we're gonna
focus on the various ways an app should
be marketed and in a very streamlined
manner we'll talk about the before in
the after tactics so when you are
launching when I said before before the
launch of we happen after the launch of
the app what sort of steps and the
strategy is an internet marketer or
digital marketer on an app marketer
whatever you want to call that should be
take it alright now how mobile apps are
going brand awareness I've got some some
more information before we get into the
before and after guys now in terms of
brand awareness which we were talking
about a brand an application definitely
helps in making the brand you know the
brand message getting passed on people
are getting to know about your brand and
so forth also from the end engaging
engagement purpose making people stick
on to your app and letting them know
that it has got a value for you and if
they find at the end customers of the
users of your app or finding value
definitely it's got it's going to be
more of engagement which will ultimately
lead to brands taking under the mind of
those customers of those users of the
app easy functionality ability to go
ahead and share across the app amongst
others I mean these are some more ways
to which the apps are able
to make the end audience know about the
brand right so easily functionality at
the end we'll have will resolve into
more stickiness more people going to
heaven finding it favorable to use
across the app and then also going
heaven sharing it with their friends and
families over the social networks
whatever the social networking deeper
content and engagement we have spoken
about and also creating touch points for
the brand at deeper level so in the
customers pocket so these are various
ways to which mobile apps have been able
to grow the brand awareness now not just
this particular brand awareness
perspective there are various other
goals which mobile app marketing really
looks at now these are some examples
which I've got onto the slide over here
number of app downloads whether it's an
iOS app or an Android app these are the
coals which one looks at so when you are
marking across an app you're looking for
maximum downloads because at the end of
the day if you are working even as a
publisher you're getting paid for every
download or if you're working as an
advertiser you want more people to come
onto your app download it happen once
they're gonna download and engage with
your app definitely more sales more
other than welcome across then it's all
about our to having loyal users who
would make in-app purchases share with
the friends through social media through
messaging through email and so forth
giving a higher App Store ranking which
is another name of search engine
optimization that is precisely App Store
optimization so that's the new search
engine optimization where you are going
ahead and doing several on page off page
optimization through your attacks so
that the event higher episode in generic
keywords certain generic search phrases
which your potential audience would type
in will definitely talk about App Store
optimization in a nutshell I've got a
certain slide for that but definitely it
could be talked about in weight would be
there or how to really go ahead and make
your app discoverable within the app
store whether it's a Google Play Store
or an Apple Play Store and so forth also
you look at
other conversions being making people
create account on your apps also within
a preference of what that would help in
the virality and also increasing
lifetime customer value also optimizing
the advertising spend across the paid ad
platforms the post download events - so
when we our customers have are coming
back to your app again again there is a
relationship which is getting built up
through them so through different
channels whether it's through the app to
the website social media and you go
ahead and offer them across various
loyalty programs so that it helps in
bringing in more revenue for the
organization and so forth Plus also in
here the objective with mobile app
marketing is to go ahead and get much
more engagement on the social media
platforms more better word-of-mouth
better positive positive word-of-mouth
precisely about your breath now there is
a biggest challenge in the war the app
market what is it there are millions of
apps in the App Store so if you look at
the numbers I mean they're increasing
massively they're millions of apps in
the App Store's we've got way too bigger
numbers for the Apple Store and bit
lesser for the Google Play Store which
is the Android one but still it's it's
doing exponentially high the growth rate
is pretty huge and as a result what
happens is it becomes a challenge for
the marketers for the app owner then
there are several apps which are getting
introduced daily which are you know
they're going every day
the competition is absolutely for
increasing right so what is it that one
needs to do as a marketer to really make
people successful it is all about
looking for a differentiation along with
the way you're gonna market it across
you need to have a differentiating
factor which the marketer has to go
ahead and promote across on several
places when that those places which I'm
talking about are in the offline
marketing in the online market and
within the online also
it's in the mobile version of the
desktop version right so look out for
the differentiation what your app has
got to do with your competitors having
ready God all right here we got certain
point there is which talked about the
ways which one can really make an app
marketing successful so one of the keys
to have marketing success I've already
spoken about the differentiation part
right and that's what number one pointer
says having product quality so having a
stronger nap when I say strong an app it
could be from the value perspective it
could be also from any creative element
you are adding onto your app something
which nobody has else has got which is
the differentiation part so you you as
an app owner or the app creator or
whatsoever have to really look for the
quality for the differentiation when I
say quality it also gets extended to the
usage of the app which doesn't have any
bugs or crashes which is the most common
pitfall which has been seen observed in
various marketing of a program so in
ways my apps marketing the crashes and
the bugs have been their real cause for
the non success of the app so
communicating with the customers over
issues to encourage loyalty that's
absolutely important you need to make
sure you that you inform your customers
that it is a stronger platform which is
going to offer such and such value for
what you're looking at the other key
element is to create a cross a buzz so
that goes hand in hand with the other
sort of marketing tactics tools it is
all about making people know about your
app stimulating various positive
discussions and brand buzz among
influencers in the target customer
community who soever whom you feel are
going to be the potential audience to
make sure you go ahead and get the get
the conversations up on those platform
where your target audiences gonna be
there right
amongst the app reviewers so their
various influencers tech law
words out reviewers whom you should
really make your you know you should
network with so that at the end of the
day they're the ones who are who are
influences and Hoover now gave you a lot
of lot of eyeballs a lot of positive
news spread out by them is going to have
a high impact estimator you going ahead
and for sounding like an advertiser on
together so that's another one creating
a bus and the other element which is key
to an ad marketing success is all about
getting found in the app store I spoke
about that which is App Store
optimization this is the organic way of
influencing the overall app store
Mochrie going ahead and promoting across
your app in the optimization space where
you're not paying anything to any
platform any sort of an ad exchange it's
all about going ahead and creating
valuable content in folio an app so
whenever you submitting a cross and are
resisting across a half of the stores
the app stores whether it's the Apple or
the Google they're the Android one it's
all about doing it and selecting the
right search phrases which you feel your
friend audience are going to be typing
in and also making sure that category
underneath which the app is getting
saved the cross that category isn't
really competitive if you are looking
for submitting your app in the most
preferable the most favorable category
which is highly competitive that's not
the right way to do it
so maybe you're not you know going to
get across higher position for your
favorable category so easily but the
second most favorable or the third most
favorable which is not that competitive
in the initial phase that one should be
used across so that ultimately if in the
other category in your office or rises
in terms of the ranking it's always
going to get you across more eyeballs
and it's also you're going to fetch you
more downloads and so forth right so
using App Store optimization best
practices which are quite a lot
watch pace a bit on that and this which
would easily help in hitting the app
found across in the App Store the Google
Play and so forth also creating
animation bust along with App Store I
would also talk about when your app gets
find across with the category it's also
the screenshots guys so you must have
seen whenever you are finding across for
an app the overall description of an app
really matters the overall icon of the
app also plays a very important role the
more catchy the more attractive an icon
of the app is the description also needs
to be more way too attractive and more
catchy that's the text along with that
it is the screen shots of the app which
depicts how the app overall navigation
is you were on interfaces so creating
across great attractive screenshots I
believe everybody is able to understand
what screenshots I am talking about
within the app is rich and you have
where you find the app you have the icon
the description the category name and
also if there is a price attached to it
the install button and also the
screenshots which talks about what is
going to be the layout of the screen one
and the screen two and the screen three
whatever major screens are there you go
ahead and put that across so the screens
should be able to give a cross an
appropriate picture do the visitor on
how the app is going to be like so that
is a lot of selling which gets done at
the apps within the app store itself
getting people onto the app store and
making your app found is not the end of
the story it is also about doing it and
convincing them and then also it goes
further when the app is being downloaded
across how the app is really engaging
and how well are you really going to
heaven sending reminders and so forth
through your and and furthermore you
know promotional offers to your app
users so that they're being reminded
that yes they have downloaded an app and
it's not just there to stick around on
the operating system and that's it it
has to be more used as well and there
has to be more shareability being done
across
after talking about all these but Swiney
opposed the app the other key element
for making an app successful is creating
an initial burst which is the peer
element after the unpaid that's at the
organic or the optimization one it is
all about utilizing the paid advertising
in the most appropriate manner and also
utilizing the existing customer
platforms
when I say existing customer platforms
that goes without saying you jump on to
making an app only after you have made a
desktop website a mobile website and so
forth you go ahead and you utilize those
platforms texting to your customers and
also emailing other marketing activities
which are being done across whether to
do with emails and text even those needs
to be used to pass perfectly for
creating the initial burst and getting
more downloads and only these downloads
are gonna make across a big difference
in the overall app ranking so if you're
talking about App Store optimization I
was talking about it's you know getting
on to it's finalizing and freezing onto
the search terms is very important thing
if you are freezing on to a wrong search
term for optimizing your website
ultimately your marketing plan will go
for that down but there are more things
to it there more things to App Store
optimization and that is also the
downloads so downloads
along with app reviews also live very
white and role in being ranking of the
app alright so that is another thing
which will help across in spurring the
organic growth and so forth all right so
that's an another one and then the other
thing with up with which a marketer
would help in making the app you know a
successful thing altogether is to
encourage sharing so if you as a
marketer are able to encourage across
your existing app users to go ahead and
share across the app with other people
and that would only happen if you
incorporate social sharing
the email refills text messaging I'll
and you give across some a motivation
some benefit some other freebies maybe
which would encourage people to go ahead
and share a cross or app so the it goes
without saying the overall product has
to be strong that it automatically leads
to sharing of the app and it has to be
coupled up with the strong product has
to be coupled up with being social
sharing buttons embed embedding ness and
also the email referrals and also those
reference schemes where you are
rewarding the existing customers for
sharing the app with their friends and
families and colleagues and their
connections and so forth the other
element which would help in app
marketing successful is for requesting
for feedback and the ratings so ratings
feedbacks reviews these are the other
things which ultimately leads to a lot
of app installs because it's it's a it's
all about the reputation which matters a
lot if people aren't liking it and
they're talking about it definitely and
bringing more referral business
automatically people who are can you
know who are much more into knowing what
others have what benefited out of it
they will they do look for reviews and
it's a major it's a major Internet users
or the mobile app users who cause for
reading the reviews first and then
deciding whether to go for installing
the app or not how that app has helped
others the overall testimonials and the
reviews whatever you wanna call that
that is something which works the best
along with that these reviews also play
a very vital role in the App Store
ranking in the App Store optimization so
downloads along with the reviews which I
was talking about they both play a very
vital role which is a sort of an off
page optimization it is a source to sort
of an off page optimization for the apps
alright the other thing is for making an
app successful is to track and measure
which is all about embedding analytics
do
and then measuring with the right
matrices on how well your app is doing
how well your app is doing in terms of
getting traffic from the organic space
and also getting traffic from the paid
channels and so forth right so that's
about another that's the other element
which would lead to marketing app
marketing success and the last one is
leveraging other channels if you talk
about other channels these are primarily
the social media email marketing the
texting and so forth which would help in
promoting across the app and cleaning
past perfect landing pages that's
another one if you've got landing pages
which specifically talked about what one
can really get across from an app that's
something which would do the overall
talking do the overall
selling of the app to the end customer
all right so these are the key elements
which would help in making an app
successful now be you'll definitely now
get into the pre-launch and the post
launch there are certain pointers which
talks about what all things should be
done with regards to public relations
promoting the app and also the
pre-launch all right so building buzz
with a well before launch that's an
important thing with when it comes down
to pre-launch so before you were going
ahead with launching in your app you go
ahead and let the entire target audience
know about your app with building a buzz
on several websites there are press
release sites where reviews of apps are
also there and so forth there are blogs
there are tech bloggers which are
influencers we spoke about and these
they're to target people and they have a
fan following and when they talk about
your app that will always gonna have
positive impact also the other thing is
to release a sneak peek for the
journalists and for creating the
relation we spoke about this creating
relationships relationships to be
nurtured in the new and notable
wayfinding also a news for the news body
angle and also encouraging the existing
app customers to go ahead and promote it
so when you go ahead and give them sort
of motivation certain freebies to go
ahead and do this overall social share
and promotions now talking in bit detail
about what App Store optimization is so
you can do all the PR in the world but
if you cannot find the app right to
download it it's gonna be all together
or disaster you have to make sure that
you do everything right in terms of
making your app visible across for the
right search phrase in the App Store
so App Store big differs across for both
the platforms for the iOS and for the
Android and an app store strategy that
requires the same elements which are
there in the which which one does for
optimizing the website for the search
engines so for the search engines what
all rules are being taken into
consideration quite many of them are
similarly taken into consideration and
then implemented when it comes down to
optimizing the app for the app stores or
the Google Play Store right the Android
and the iOS initially you go ahead and
get started with doing a competitor
analysis look at what are what all your
competitors are doing with their apps
the kind of search places they're using
with their app the kind of functionality
which they're offering and how well have
you design your app how different you've
designed your app as compared to your
competitor and so forth then doing in
the keyword research where you
definitely look into your competitors
keywords do not miss forward it's pretty
simple by going into your competitors
app and seeing the kind of the keywords
the words which have been put in a cross
by a competitor in the hack description
and so forth the other thing with the
App Store optimization is all about
doing it and submitting the keywords so
keywords are those search places which
you are looking for but your end
audience definitely do type in it's it's
been seen that's quite a many app
creators they do this mistake of
selecting the Kievan as a brand name so
if you are not promoting your brand
aggressively and you are just going
ahead and not optimizing your app for
that
for your brand name it's never gonna
give you get some results because nobody
knows about your brand why on earth
would you really go ahead and promote
across an app for keyword which is a
brand name many people searching across
for apps with the aural generic term
which your app would provide a cross
right maybe somebody would type in a
cross app for you know games for kids
apps for kids productivity apps business
apps management apps would these are the
certain phases very generic phases for
which the competition is also higher and
that profits you much more results but
in the initial level it's better to go
ahead and go for a bigger search phrase
for a longer key phrase because they're
more conversion related and also they've
got lesser competition but make sure
they are not your brand so those longer
key phrases are generic and very
specific to what category your app falls
in what value your apps provides which
your end audience would also type in and
doesn't have the brand name a keyword
rich in conversion optimizer app store
description is needed we have spoken
about it
also having localized information in the
languages which your end audience do
understand and type in and they're
searching for right along with coupled
with that the reviews and ratings in the
same language not something which should
be done across
yes I've already spoken about this which
is the school screenshots having high
quality screenshots and also the videos
right the app demonstration with us also
play a very vital role which really
leads to you know conversion off of
those people who are coming and seeing
your app and then they're trying to
decide whether to go ahead and download
the app and not so reviews high screens
high quality screenshots videos the
demonstration video
they threw our to be up way to a bigger
element when it comes down to App Store
optimization - and also making your
visitors turn into potential clients and
customers also engaging reviews and
ratings and also push notifications
should we leave this to us perfectly
that also helps an App Store
optimization and also reminding the
existing app for users to go ahead and
keep engaging with the app on an ongoing
basis suppose not all right so we gotta
have screen over here we go to slide
which talks about the painter paint
advertising paid advertising is
precisely all about all right so if we
talk about paid advertising guys this is
done across with the help of several
several app you know networks several ad
networks which enables app promotion on
several other websites meant primarily
the mobile web sites and also different
app mobile mobile absolutely some of
those some of those advertising channels
are like ad enablers I add in mobi AdMob
tab Joey jump tab there are real-time
bidding exchanges Facebook exchange with
the help of Google AdWords - you're able
to promote across our app in these
search ads as well if somebody is doing
doing a search on a mobile search engine
the mobile version of the Google search
engine and so forth then there are
display on types like the in-app ads
which are expanded banners as you can
see over here right so the moment you go
ahead and click one of those there are
interstitials mobile banner ads rich
media which are the videos and so forth
so there quite a many ways through which
you can promote across an app to the
paid they can be a way to bigger session
on to how to create these ads the paid
ads and get across value out of it the
way the other
I paid elements the paid marketing the
pale advertisement works in the desktop
very similar to that we got the mobile
app version there are certain
functionalities which do differ but the
basic mechanism the matrices works
similar one of the metrics which would
differ in the mobile app marketing is
the overall cost per app download and
over there you majorly try to lower down
the cost per impression or cost per
click right so how many downloads you
got across and how many so that that's
something which has been measured in
order to see the performance of a
campaign in a mobile app whereas in the
in the other you always know for the
different conversions conversion could
be a sale in a different campaign or it
can be a form fill up and so forth
whereas in the mobile app you primarily
focus on the downloads and then later
you have further more engagement related
campaigns where you're looking at people
spending more time and sharing your apps
and doing in approaches and so so for
the best marketing to get to the top of
a category you always need to have
better reviews and maximum downloads in
minimum time if you're getting maximum
downloads it in minimum time the overall
algorithm of these apps the App Store
they go ahead and pushing across your
app onto the top alright so looking for
increasing your organic downloads and
also for gaining ranking in the which
would help you in gaining ranking in the
App Store this has to be coupled up with
two things the organic and the paid one
the paid one to which you're able to
score downloads in a shorter span of
time now many would say the heiner cash
you have the higher budget you have
you're always going to have benefit
there are no doubts about that if you're
able to push in and push in more money
into it which will help you get a good
amount of downloads you're always going
to get benefit but nevertheless if even
if you're a small business owner you do
not have those budgets then it's all
about when you have in creating a
differentiating factor into your product
that will only can really stand out and
win this particular path
we love making your app stand out and do
well as compared to your competitors and
so forth and the other thing is cross
and promotion we've already spoken about
that where you are using emails and so
forth your mobile websites your texting
and so forth to go ahead and promote
across your mobile app that's what the
screenshot also talks about on your
website you have the links on the mobile
website you've got links which talks
about go ahead and click on at this and
get the app and so forth alright and
another one is reffering marketing
you've already spoken about this which
helps in making other people go ahead
and spread out the world and also use a
cart using a cross push notifications
here's the example you're looking for
feedback you provided cross for you send
a cross push notifications to take
feedback to take reviews and ultimately
going ahead and amplifying the entire
process so here is the entire bandwagon
which talks about the mobile marketing
Genevan are better at it is more public
relations exercises to be done with the
help of paid ads cross promotion App
Store optimization and sharing across on
social media you do go ahead and push it
across her land working totally now
whatever we have discussed so far I'm
just going to be quick in terms of for
the pre-launch in the post launch app
marketing stuff so things which I have
discussed i've been divided into pre and
post port that was an overall mix of
them now in a world classification there
are going to be a few things which are
new which I haven't spoken about now and
they're going to be a few things which
have already been spoken about so I'm
going to get started with the pre launch
marketing activities which should be
done here the nine steps which I have
highlighted which one should be doing to
market an app with launch number one is
to know your app for so it all starts
with getting to know what you are really
going at and clearly across in the
development stage of a wrap go ahead and
create a plus a list of very successful
apps in that same segment
and check out how these very successful
apps have really gone ahead and provided
value to the end customers how they
already benefited the end customers and
what how and strategies what are things
they did in terms of getting profit then
that kind of icon they created the name
that they signed the app review and the
screenshots and so forth
number two element with regards to the
pre launch before the launch it's all
about winning and choosing a good name
for your app now this is a very
subjective what is a good name is really
subjective something which is good for
me might not be good for the other
person it's always better to go ahead
and ask him do a sort of primary
feedback a primary you know research go
and do across a primary research from
amongst you know audience in terms of
what was what name sounds better to them
Seeger didn't take across certain names
and then research do talking to their
potential audience at what sounds good
to them and so forth ultimately you're
not using your logics and that you are
ultimately listening from the horse's
mouth
what was my work right make sure once
you use across important keywords and so
forth something which is memorable
people are able to save pretty easily
and so forth right and do not infringe
any trademarks that's another thing to
be really careful about when you're
choosing for a good name for a number
thing you've already spoken about that
which is going in and finding across
your competitors so observe what the
other developers have done in terms of
making an app successful right look at
competitors each and everything the
keywords they have used a kind of layout
they had the ease availability the
social icons now you know embedment the
share functionality how people can go
ahead and share across an app and the
reviews push notifications being sent
across for asking for those and so forth
so that's another thing looking at your
competitors they're started see their
overall product the way they have marked
the fourth element which needs
to be done before launching the my app
is to choose right category I did talk
about the category stuff that maybe you
might not go for the most favorite
category you might go ahead and go for
the second most favorite or the third
most favorite category just because of
the reason the first most favorite
category is pretty competitive right now
always estimate the number of downloads
you will be needing across to rank
higher than the specific category there
like written plenty of downloads which
are going to be needed because it's not
a brain it wouldn't just use that
category type yeah and in select that
category calculate your strength the
more competitive or category the more
downloads you will get but that's
something which should be done at a
later stage
later on so this unlevel game altogether
you should be going with a lesser
competitive category ranking it there
and then changing the category and
making it rank high above these highly
competitive even highly competitive
category get maximum downloads number
first is to go in and create an amazing
icon similar logic applies here with
icon to what logically applied for the
name so it's all about going ahead and
creating icon that matters a lot which
is more catchy but it's easily
recognizable knowing trademark
infringement is being done nice going
here and asking across doing a family
research master target audience do
deliver you know better style which is
more recognizable more easily you know
we were you able it doesn't really cause
it invitation to the eyes of your end
customer so these are this pretty simple
stuff which everybody knows but some
people are not able to apply them take a
notice of it when they're doing the
applying and all the exact marketing
stuff the sixth element we already
spoken word which is to take great great
high quality screenshots which to talk
about which gives a overall picture to
the end customer to the visitor that
what sort of product would they really
to see even there download the app will
it gonna be pretty interesting for them
and so forth that's what the screenshot
alone talked about so that's the sales
man for your app which will really good
work along with screenshots the
descriptions reviews name and the icon
it's also the demonstration video which
also works as a sales person for you
right now this is the demo video which
I've been talking about seventh point
number seven which is making an
effective app demo video explain what
the app does make it much more memorable
informative and exciting convince the
users to why should they really go ahead
and download or buy the app right that's
another thing if they are getting
convinced so again it's our doing a beta
version trying our testing a beta
version where you are having a group
discussion amongst a focus group where
you have certain set of different
targeted audiences or give you various
different opinions on whether they liked
the video but didn't like the app for
why should they go ahead and buy the app
or download the app after watching the
video desktop video talk about that is
the video given across that message all
these kind of elements should be done
across by the math element also we spoke
about that which is to have a great
landing page which does the overall
selling of your app in terms of what the
app is make sure there is proper
optimisation being done for that
specific landing page also which is
promoting across your app write good
title description which has got keywords
and vetted into it right showcasing your
apps finest feature how it is different
from the others and do not forget to
include across the other elements which
is the reviews the screenshots high
quality screenshots the demonstration
video and so forth right and the number
9's the last one is to go ahead and
cleared a possibility help of the
pre-release pass basically so make sure
you use across various review sites some
of one of them being on the main pre-ops
calm which helps in introducing new apps
to various users and the marketplace
prior to its release start collecting
day
well ahead of your launch and contact
everyone once the app goes like so
that's the last thing which one should
be doing before the launch of the app
I'd say about the launch done then what
to do next now we already spoken about
that also I'm just going to be quick
onto this and that's when we the last
thing that's for the webinar today the
five steps which marketer should be
doing to market a mobile app after the
launch it's all about going Evan pushing
it for as many downloads in the very
first few days or the weeks and so forth
ultimately you have to go ahead and give
some of the other motivation some or the
other freebie may be to get maximum
downloads people who download only if
they have got certain you know reason
for that you need to provide a reason
for that provide a free trial let them
know that this app download is worth
this much but we were running a
one-month free trial and only for this
particular month since it's an
introductory offer and so forth should
we not this should be done in the
initial phase in that - for some time to
increase the downloads which will
ultimately help in App Store
optimization bringing the app and puffin
so we spoke about getting to know how
the app marketing is performing and
that's very essentially the moment you
have launched it it's necessary to go
ahead and sign up for the analytics app
it could be various analytics I mean you
can choose and present in great
analytics platform one of them
my favorite is Mixpanel or Google
Analytics also helps you in seeing
across the entire matrices the
performance with the help of all the
possible matrices in the Google mobile
app analytics and they're pretty big
plenty of others to write like app any
and number third is to reach out to the
top media we only spoke about that to
making sure that you're connecting
across to the influencers trading in
France press releases and forming the
right bio of the founders pushing that
across with the help of various press
release sites various journalists and
editors and through several other
socially
sites number fault after the launch for
promoting across the app is to provide
incentives you know internet users to go
ahead and share the app on their
personal social their personal profiles
on we all various social networking
websites and also give them offers
freebies and certain you know reasons to
go ahead and read and review the app
right so that's another and the last one
as we all did this cussed me as we spoke
about it it's about the promotion we
didn't this is I'm sorry as I pointed
that out is going ahead and promoting
across the app on several advertising
platforms right so those being AdMob in
mobi and several others so rise to the
top of the charts with the help of your
app marketing keep for doing these tasks
and just enjoy marketing your app that's
all from my end guys thank you so much
I'm just going to ask Richard to step in
and take over the control and excellent
Nick and thank you thank you for your
expertise today I always loved Nick's
talks because I'm always learning
something that's one of the really
wonderful things I get for working in
the background was simply learned as I
get to always increase my knowledge
every day thank you very lucky we view
at this point go ahead and we're going
to do two things at the same time I'm
gonna take over the screen and launch a
poll for the next five to ten minutes as
part of simply learned because they're
the ones sponsoring the webinar so you
can come in here and have these
expertise from people like Nick so if
you ever take a chance to go and answer
that that is great if you have like a
team training for your group or maybe
your own path maybe you're a company
that's building an app and you want to
get some training for your marketing
team so they know what's going on you
certainly can contract this for a whole
team and then if you're just an
individual maybe you're doing your own
entrepreneurialship and you really need
to get some more knowledge than
something more in-depth and how you're
going to do the marketing great place to
get certified in that
while we're doing that it says going to
be two things at once one of the
questions it always comes up is other
recordings for the session and yes we do
record all the sessions you can get a
copy of the recording or a link for that
copy but going to simply learn comm go
under the click on support and request
it just let them know hey I was there on
such-and-such a morning and such as this
time for Nick I'm gonna let them know
you know Nick creating a killer
marketing plan for your app just put
that in there and they'll know what that
is and they'll send you back an email
with that link at this point we do have
questions for Nick so if you have any
questions as far as your own company
path or something specific a great time
to post it we're going to start with a
question from Kunal has a wonderful
question and he's wondering according to
your experience and assuming Nick
because I don't have experience in this
what would the average lifespan and
lifecycle of an app be if it's gaming
utility news music do you have any
experience as to how long these
different apps last or is there kind of
like general market trends on them Nick
alright that's that's great question
from my experience of gaming has the
shortest life cycle with regards to news
definitely that's more from the serious
stuff that has much much longer life
cycle if I talk about a shorter order
longer a gaming might have six months to
a year our maximum couple of years with
regards to what I've seen so far and
I'll give it the reasons why also with
regards to news I've seen great apps
news news apps doing pretty well even
for the past 5 7 years the overall
reason to it is the way you have been
able to cope up with the change and able
to provide value to your end customers
so if you are changing yourself
consistently and you know providing
something or the other new your end
customers will definitely stay there for
long period of time but with definitely
with the type of business the industry
you're in the things do matter like I
said with gaming
pretty less just because nobody wants to
play the same game for years and years
they do want to jump in the it's the
trades it's a trade of the audience
whereas the audience which consuming
news piece kind of stuff they're not
hoppers they're they're more of
loyalists I was loyal
you know they don't want to stick to or
space they want to stick to a particular
absence they've gotten used to it and
they're not they're reluctant in terms
of using a new app and you know checking
out some more stuff so differs from
situation to situation in the steel
industry with the help of my example
I've given you a couple of industries
example yeah excellent Thank You Nick we
are one coming in from Rock Tim how do I
decide if I need a nap suppose I have a
web store or a health service website
which is doing good how do I decide if
and when I need a nap
able to get all that yeah I see I've got
a pretty pretty simple answer in one
simple line look for your competitors if
you don't want to be a leader in terms
of being the first one to put and get an
app in the our segment then and you're
just deciding whether you should get an
app for your business you know you
already have all the various resources
we've got the web side you've got the
mobile web side apart several other
stuff several other resources and now
you're not even decide with the group in
Weston in mobile also then or just study
your competition just study your
competitors how well they are doing if
they've got a mobile apps but the god
mobile apps how is how how is that
really treating out looking for them
is it helping them to get business isn't
helping them to get business not just on
the app but also in the brand awareness
and brand much better brand visibility
and so forth so that's the answer look
for your competition that's the one
yeah I like bail one that's really good
I did with a lot of not specifically on
the marketing side but I deal with
startups in our area and there's a lot
of questions like that always coming in
let's see we have from a more direct
question I'm in the process of coming
out with an on-demand dating app it's
pretty different from anything I've seen
out there are there any additional steps
for marketing how can I reach out to
people right now oh they the basics are
pretty simple
the basics are same the ground rules
remain the same whether it's a dating
app or whether it's a matrimonial or a
job portal or so forth the organic and
the Payette these are the two ways
underneath we've got several different
ways to promote it so the getting good
reviews getting good icon giving you
know you know tired quality screenshots
and product demonstration that holds
true for even a dating app however any
kind of an app so organic side
definitely you need to look for more
more downloads with the help of this and
also would be helpful so the thing which
would differ over here is the kind is
the places when your app advertisement
would go so in the paid advertising more
or less when it comes down to targeting
your app making sure you're putting in
money in the right places showing your
banner ads and your video ads on the
right spot so not figure 4 if you're
targeting the wrong audience if you're
targeting the wrong platforms that were
really hits it back that will get back
and that could eat up your money so
that's the only thing which would differ
whether you're a dating app or you are
some other otherwise the ground rule
remains the same excellent excellent
Betsy bear with me because it's I have
to kind of read through these a little
bit myself and I was trying to figure
out which questions kind of grouped
together there's a lot of them are
really specific just like that one was
specific for an industry someone was
asking about downloading apps let's see
let me just go ahead read it what is
your recommendation for a promotion of
the app to a closed or limited
app like a conference app which are
usually downloaded in the last minute
and then installed after your event is
over so something like our WebEx what's
your suggestion for someone doing apps
that are similar to that
that's from Austin Hall okay so if it's
a pretty niche audience and you're
talking about audience within an
organization then it's pretty easy I
mean you've got their contact you've got
their emails you covered texting number
so you're good in that ways you're not
gonna use across the paid versions the
paid paid way of promoting it across you
do not need any App Store optimization -
you just need to go ahead and spread the
word out and through the offline
marketing ways you just need to spread
out the words would be in the online
version just to behalf of emails and so
forth if the audience is known to you
that's in a scenario when audience is
known to you if the audience is not
known to you instead it's a niche
audience then in the paid version you
always have the functionality of going
local so if it's a pretty nice segue
then you know your audience is reciting
across in a very specific zone very
specific even a zip code I would say the
geographic targeting the interest based
targeting what people what your interest
for your audience is interested in even
the remarketing all these
functionalities of reading was there
then in that sense do not focus more on
App Store optimization just focus more
on the paid advertisement how are you
going to go ahead and do the right set
of targeting there so that's the answer
you know the audience or we don't know
the audience okay excellent that makes a
lot of sense and oops I just closed out
one window give me just a second to get
on there there we go
always a technical challenge you click
one thing in three windows closed we
have time for just a couple more
questions I got on here and also your
welcome mat he sent - thanks and the
thanks Nick from sneh Hall always nice
to hear the feedback so we know you guys
are listening and then I have two more
questions were going to take one another
one from Kunal
how to regain the Mau and the DA you if
an app is losing traction or it's a pill
you have any suggestions if the the apps
going downhill how to regain that that
market yeah I believe it it's all about
doing an overall overhaul of the entire
business model what your app was
supposed to achieve maybe it was it is
not living up to the expectations of
your own customers that case it's all
about listening to your end customers
listening to what their competitors are
like lighting so whatever app is being
liked by your competitors you need to be
going ahead and studying that for
precisely getting deeper dive into what
works and what not what's being like
what are the lights of this thing so
pretty easy stuff in terms of knowing
your audience furthermore and seeing
which audience is what which apps your
audience are liking the best and taking
lessons from there and then implementing
otherwise again the promotional rules
though whether it's the organic quality
paid they was the best
it is a lot of fermentation in
combination which is needed when it
comes down to the marketing and
promoting your app so some of the public
in the publishers where your app is
getting promoted might not work for you
initially but later on with a lot of
experimentation and permutation and
combination you might find the right
recipe whether with the perfect features
and benefits at a store excellent
and then let's see let me go ahead and
get a question from Ricardo great name
by the way is Ricardo oh hi Nick yeah I
know it's probably difficult to say
depending on the market but if you had a
limited budget where would you invest
more which steps are the pre and after
launch are the most valuable in terms of
investment biggest bang for the buck
good so here you're sort of your chart
of budgets it's the optimization pretty
simple in there no second thoughts
that and when it comes down to the
organic I meant to say the App Store
optimization so when you cannot spend in
more from the money perspective than you
can spend in more from the time
perspective and that what happens in
every specific business when you are
when you are a start-up when you are you
know having difficulties or not I would
say that because you've got distractions
from the budget perspective but
constraints it's then you then you need
to check out more time more valuable
time I would say and it's only the
organic stuff where things like in the
before and after context I would
definitely talk about things like
selecting the icon the review getting
more reviews proper review is populating
it across on press release sites which
is not gonna cost you money you are
spending in time from your site that
case you go ahead and connect across
with journalists and do a sort of a
batter and that's something which
happens in the real case it happens in
the real time world where people are
connecting with their journalists and
you're not there they they say that we
do not have higher budgets maybe we can
offer you something else and in far
against
soy patter barter system do happens
bargaining happens across in terms of
what are we not having any financial
transaction with these bloggers tech
bloggers and journalists you're offering
them something else you're offering them
publicity with your app you're offering
them backlinks with your app and so
forth to their app so that they also get
promotion out of it they get publicity
for themselves yeah especially if you're
in the startup communities and new
entrepreneurial ships new
entrepreneurial setups certainly your
own budget zero startup cost or you know
minimal whatever you can it takes a
little bit to raise the money so those
are great great suggestions and insight
and let's say I've got we're gonna sneak
in two extra questions here I got Matt
who just sent a note in us is any advice
for funding or bringing an app to
investors what would you go show the
investors
a big one at least I've had to work with
that one before you've got to be clear
with investors and have why would your
app be successful means smoke about in
detail the King pointers while which
would make your app successful and
investors do not want to see that you're
gonna have a great video they do not
want to hear from you but you can have
great reviews they do not want to hear
that you've got to have you're gonna
have a great icon you're doing this and
that what investors really need is one
single piece of paper with numbers
that's it and you go for any pitches
where you are just reaching in investors
for funding they do not want hear
anything else just with numbers then
when the numbers sound interesting to
their ears then they go ahead and look
into your marketing overall strategy
that what would you be doing or what
have you really done are you planning to
do which wouldn't make you successful in
that all we have discussed internality
that what should be done right so it
starts with when you're talking to
investors do not talk in detail about
what we have discuss that's that step
number two step number one is to go
ahead and talk about the number of
installs you're expecting the number of
you know visitors and so forth you're
expecting and so forth that that is a
totally different ball game altogether
it starts with identifying the keywords
looking at number of competitors which
are there and what sort of numbers they
have achieved on the face of that lot of
calculation so that is pretty different
ball game altogether people you know
would have been webinar on that which is
the number crunching all the other
excellent and you get a big thank you
from Matt for that yeah we appreciate
those questions because I mean you know
this is how we learn is what are the
real life questions are coming up this
is this is where we have the webinars
and it's a as part of its big of a part
of the learning session as I going in
and studying all these different things
and then one last quick question from
Snow Hall I hope I'm saying the name
correctly one last quick question
okay how critical is a file size of an
app what is the ideal size for when
you're putting together these different
mobile apps I'm guessing is talking
about mobile apps because a computer you
don't worry so much about that
yeah see mobile app size absolutely has
got nothing to do with the marketing as
well nothing to do with whether your app
would be successful or not it's all
about making sure it's bug free it's all
about making sure the quality is perfect
even a small sliced app can really go
for a toss up if it's not being handled
correctly from the development
perspective and it's let's say it's
crashing all the way or for the users so
and oh and let's say on the other side
you've got a bigger size app in it's
it's working pretty well so there there
is no logic which says that a bigger app
a bigger sized app will crash more know
nothing of that so it totally depends
upon the technology the server size and
the database which you're putting in I
mean the entire bandwidth which is going
behind that so not goes from the
development aspect so size of the app
has got nothing to do with the success
or non-success of it's not about
critical and there's no ideal size
excellent that's thank you Nick yeah
that's always that's always agreed yes
then that's important information so a
lot of this stuff I never really think
about that because I'm always on the
development side I'll let somebody else
come to me and say hey that's too big
it's not gonna work I'm gonna go ahead
and we're gonna go ahead and round off
the session if you do have additional
questions we do have forums on simply
learn comm it's at community dot simply
learn comm or if you go to simply learn
comm you'll see a link there it takes
you to community dot something learn
comm so we do have an open forum there
if you are a member of our classes
you'll also have simply talk which is
just for people who are registered it
with simply learn so you can also go to
the simply talk forums to to ask
additional questions we have experts
that go in there regularly who answered
whatever
filled there in my I don't answer these
questions obviously concerning digital
marketing but I do answer them for the
big data Hadoop and you'll see my
picture up there a couple times Thank
You Nick for being here what a wonderful
session I certainly got a lot of
information out of it myself I see a lot
of other people by their notes they put
really got a lot of stuff out of this
webinar thank you Richard thanks
everyone for time thank it we look
forward to seeing in our classrooms and
again you can get the recordings if you
go to simply learn comm and click on
support and request it and don't forget
our forums there take care and have a
wonderful rest of the week for you
you